Welcome back guys!
Thanks for joining me today here on the king of random
Today's the big one we're finally going to be firing off
our flamethrower
We have two videos showing you how we built this flamethrower using a tank, some Co2,
a pressure washer handle and a propane torch to turn it into a flamethrower. Today we're gonna fuel it up and fire it off
For anyone who missed the build videos we'll review really quickly how this works
The Co2 cannister attaches to this nozzle here and when we open both valves our tank can fill with pressure
This tank will be holding our fuel mixture of 80% gasoline and 20% diesel.
The pressure from the Co2 will drive the fuel out the bottom of the tank
through the hose and into our power washer handle. Blowing the trigger on the handle lets the pressurized fuel fly through the power washer out
The nozzle we've added and then we'll ignite it using this propane torch we have several of these Co2
canisters which are usually used for powering paintball guns but they will work great for this as well
we're using carbon dioxide instead of compressed air
because it's extremely non flammable, it actually puts out flames this is just a safety precaution in case the flames try to travel up the
fuel and into our nozzle
There will be
CO2 spraying out with the fuel putting out any flames they get too close to the nozzle (sigh) the red cans have gasoline, the yellow can
Has diesel and we're going to make a mixture of 80% gas
20% diesel and that's gonna be our fuel for the flamethrower as an added safety measure we have a large co2 fire
extinguisher and i'm wearing a genuine
fireman's coat just to protect myself from the heat as you can see i'm mostly surrounded by dead and dry plants and i don't want
To accidentally light stuff on fire so we've got a concrete bunker( that might explain why he is demonstrating the flamethrower now after a loong time) that we're gonna shoot
Into and that should safely contain our fire let's fill up our tank charge it with co2 and give it a test shot
since i can't actually see inside the tank i'm really just kind of estimating how much gasoline and how much diesel to put in
*is there an ant in there?* right our tank is fueled up now let's add our co2
Opening this valve oh made a little popping noise hurt a little pressure change now we've pressured from the tank to the valve
When we open this valve it will add pressure, to the main tank
Funky noise alright and with that our flamethrower should be ready to go let's strap it on and try it out, oh
it's thing weighs a million pounds
Quick observation our gun appears to be leaking we have?
test-fired with this nozzle before with just water and it didn't do that so
i'm a little concerned about why it is doing it now i
Don't know it's leaking it's pressurized and sleeping so that's not great but i'm still gonna try it
For you for my first shot i'm not going, to add the flame from my propane i'm going to shoot
The fuel out of the nozzle but not ignite it just, to see how it travels here goes
( what daaaa...)Huh!
well it's certainly spraying i did think it was going to travel in more of an arc kind of like a squirt gun
But this just kind of a price is in the air i wonder if it's just cuz there's so much pressure i don't
see why that should stop us from lighting on fire let's see how it goes alright
test shot with fire
Three two one
HOLLY COW (not literally..)
fireball that's amazing oh
HOLY COW that is fantastic (*Halloween?*)
it still isn't squirting the way i thought it would when you think of a flamethrower i think most people imagine a squirt of flame
flying through the air and landing on the ground maybe soaking everything around it and fire
This isn't doing that it's also doing this i don't know what is causing this to happen i think something in our valve is not
working very well
pulsing out that's definitely not ideal
I'll keep an eye on that and in the meantime
i'm gonna shoot, the flamethrower more all right let's try this again three two one
That's amazing
My shoes have gasoline on them now i don't like that it doesn't make me feel safe
and it might be bad for them well let's just keep using it and tell them a lot of fuel then it won't trip anymore
oh *FAIL*
Doesn't matter fuel and i still have some co2
He fires i need to put out
now this tank is freezing cold your that
So when the gas inside the tank
expands to fill the larger tank it cools off a lot cooled off fast enough that the outside is just covered in frozen water vapor
The pressure washer handle that we had attached to our other gun began to malfunction
it would turn on when i squeeze the handle but it wouldn't turn off when i let go so it would just keep spraying all
of
the fuel and co2 in the tank i
Didn't want to be using a flamethrower that i didn't have the ability to turn off we actually have the same
Malfunctioning issue with two separate units of that particular spray handle so we do not recommend that you use it for this build or any
Other so we finished filming for the day and i went and got a new replacement handle at home depot
this one works well with all of our connections it actually even has a
quick-connect built into the back of it and the nozzle seems to be working out just fine as well i've tested this out with water
and it's spraying
beautifully you can see i've moved the propane tank to the side of handle that's because this one has more of an oblong shape and
The propane doesn't like to stay strapped on to the bottom of it the function is exactly the same it has a flame which ignites
the fuel it's just slightly off
To the side instead of directly underneath which our tank is ready it's fueled up it's got co2 giving you pressure let's test it out (gosh!,thought he was thomson for a moment)
that was sweet i think it went actually farther than before
and it's so warm like i can feel that on my face immediately i actually upgraded gloves to a
Something a little more rigid because before my hands would start getting hot just from the flame being squirted out that's amazing
The fireman's coat is doing an amazing job though i don't feel a thing
Anywhere i've got the coat now because i think it's gonna be a cool shot i'm just gonna shoot it inside the concrete bunker entirely
Got it
So far every time that I've used this I've opened the co2 tank and the valve into the main tank and I've just let it
pressurize it until i run out of fuel i'm gonna try something a little bit differently this time i'm gonna
Open the valve
To the main tank and then once the pressure has balanced i'm going to close it again i'm hoping that what happens is i get
more of a stream of the fuel and let's have a fine mist i've tested this exact set up with water
and it always comes out in a nice spray it shoots about 40 50 feet
water is hitting the ground and i was kind of hoping that would happen with the fuel as well
We'll see if changing the pressure makes any difference on that point?
Let's test this out with a different amount of pressure from the co2 tank
That is a lot more what i was expecting from the beginning i am afraid that the pressure is just gonna keep dropping as i'm
shooting and the flame will get closer and closer so once i don't feel like it's safe anymore i'm gonna turn it off i
Also might like the ground on fire now three two one?
that's definitely different
yeah, the grounds on fire we need to put that out
everything is on fire
That's interesting i would have thought that the pressure would have kept going down and we would have had less and less stream but as
I've been using it is just switched from squirting out to spraying out in a mist like it was when i had full pressure
and there goes try it again
That's the that's what you want, to see right there that's?
FYYAH!
Ha OOH! *not fighting*
That is one smoky dome a whole
Giant dome is basically full of smoke at this point there we go three full tank full of fuel on one tank of?
Carbon dioxide it's possible we could have even gotten the force but i did leave the small tank open this time just
To see how it affected things i do think that the lower pressure
helps use the fuel more efficiently it seems like it get a lot more burn time
when i open the tank and then close it off again for next test we're gonna actually light something on fire with a flamethrower
So i've stacked up a bunch of hay bales and we're gonna burn them three two one
AHHHH
yeah!
those are burning pretty good and  filling the bunker with smoke way faster than the flamethrower did
Oh, when it collapses i'm gonna take credit for that i made it collapse as, ami
we've tested out our flamethrower and it worked great we've lit some stuff on fire and that was way fun so the last thing i
want to try
roasting a marshmallow
actually i'm gonna do three marshmallows (poor guyz)
All at once and this is a big flame
So we've got big marshmallows i do have a feeling that these marshmallows will end up a little well-done
FIRE IN THE HOLE!
*So well done* Just, the way i like them oh no starting, to sag he's gonna grip oh
there you have it a home-built flamethrower in all of its amazing glory we had a few different types of shots we had the fuel
aerosol eyes which made sort of a line of fireball
sometimes when we headed at lower pressure it squirted an in nice stream that was all on fire i really like that one because it
just
sort of lit everything on fire that it touched it was really cool
We used it to light some hay bales on fire and those went up in a flash and we also tried using it for cooking
which
didn't turn out so perfect i hope you've really enjoyed watching this flamethrower get used it was a ton of fun for me of course
if you go ahead and build one of these yourselves please take every possible safety
precaution
Fortunately i was able to get an actual fire coat which did an amazing job no matter how hot the flame was on my hands
Or my face i didn't feel a thing through the coat
always be aware of your surroundings don't use a flame thrower somewhere where you can light everything on fire we had a couple of times
Where we lit a little bit of the grass on fire but we were carefully watching and we were able to put it out quickly
before it spread anywhere also be careful with your equipment our first spray handle malfunction and we weren't able to keep using it
i got another handle that worked much better
Even it had some problems where it would drip out of the end there are a couple of times the end of the gun actually
A little on fire
So just be a very aware of everything that's happening if your equipment have someone standing by that has wet towels and a fire extinguisher
to put anything out just in case there's a problem
There you have it i know a lot of you were very excited about this video (exhausted makin the captions...jk) and so was i this was
So much, fun to do and i think it looked amazing
thank you for joining us for this project today and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
Hmm don't show that make it seem like i eat it that's a lot of marshmallow
well there are some fuel left in
that right there is a little more well done than i like my marshmallow
turns out a flamethrower might not be the best tool for cooking
hey guys grant here just want to pop in with a quick update that the king of random brand is
expanding nate's here because you wanted more diy more variety more frequent videos and together we're all making that happen thanks for your support (And peace out from "chaoster61" ur caption guy...)